hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 8
video just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet
a lot of reverse-flash making plants
against future flash Barry so I'll
explain what's going on there is a new
round of the flash ring giveaway going
on right now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so you don't miss
anything during the break there's a
couple really weird things that are
happening with legends of tomorrow when
all the DC shows come back in January
like it's moving to a new night it'll
air after the flash but I'll remind
everyone at the end of this and I have a
flash trailer video that I'll post this
weekend and I'll remind everyone again
in that so no worries but legends of
tomorrow does the untouchables it's
called the Chicago Way it's all about Al
Capone big gang era Chicago so what an
appropriate episode to marshal the
Legion of Doom Malcolm Merlyn makes his
entrance captain cold appearance to who
was having a visitation ghost of
Christmas past present future style they
kind of did that with an arrow episode a
couple seasons ago where they did go so
past present and future as a mid-season
finale like as their Christmas episode
so I felt that it a really good job with
all the Chicago stuff it was a lot of
fun they did great costumes they did a
good job of molding the legends of
tomorrow music to 1920s big band style
like they had a version of the theme
song played by a big band in the
background and it was a big mythology
episode so sometimes you have adventures
that are really one-off they don't
really push the story forward then you
have the mythology episodes where you
have like the Legion of Doom explaining
what it is that they're trying to do you
learn all about the talismans in the
Spear of Destiny so this is huge
obviously you know about the infinity
gems in the Marvel Universe just really
powerful artifacts that they can use to
reshape reality like time space the soul
so in the DC Universe they do have a lot
of very powerful magical artifacts but
the way the reverse-flash wants to use
the spear of destiny is this kind of
like the reality gem he wants to use it
to reshape reality to suit his design
and the producers have already explained
what that is so bring
all the way back to the flash season one
in for a lot of you flash comic book
readers this is nothing new there is one
thing that the reverse-flash wants to do
in his lifetime and that is to kill
Barry Allen without erasing himself from
the timeline that's like his one thing
that he wants to do he is stuck on it
every action he takes is a step closer
to that goal
so just because he's on legends of
tomorrow forming this Alliance the
Legion of Doom I'll talk about that in a
second because I feel like the
reverse-flash doesn't have friends
so they've softened him up just a little
bit for this but the reverse-flash
really just wants to get rid of Barry
that's what he's going to use the spear
of destiny for to rewrite a new reality
without Barry Allen in it so that is
what's going to be the season finale
there are 17 episodes this season they
actually added a couple episodes during
the middle of the run because the
network liked what they were doing so
much like okay people are watching this
now it's a good show please give us some
more episodes on the back end so they
ordered like four extra episodes so it's
basically like an extra month of legends
of tomorrow in the spring when
everything comes back but some of my
other favorite things from this episode
were heatwave and vixen teaming up as
Bonnie and Clyde like he was trying to
teach her that sometimes it's more fun
to be the bad guy and she's trying to
show him that he's not all that bad like
he wants to be a team player but it's
not in his nature so that's where you
get the Captain Cold entrance so it was
a lot of fun seeing him back but he's
head space Captain Cold so he's not back
physically think he's still dead in this
continuity but because it's the comic
books you can bring people back in all
kinds of ways just look at the people
over on arrow I don't want to spoil that
if you haven't seen the arrow midseason
finale but let's just say surprise comic
book twist in the final moments of that
episode but if you haven't watched the
flash season one in a while they had a
couple Easter eggs for that where he
stole Martin Stein's DNA to become him
like he said I've changed this a little
it used to just kill people now it's
just going to be excruciating ly painful
so if you remember season 1 eobard
thawne took the DNA from original earth
1 Harrison wells became him and that's
how you get to reverse flash in disguise
for the entirety of
and one so when he did that to harrison
wells it turned him into this desiccated
corpse so that's what he was doing to
martin stein if that wasn't clear but
they finally make use of rip hunters
secret room of weapons so they have a
speedster gun they can finally fight the
reverse-flash and this is the first
episode where they actually refer to him
as the speedster they learn who he is
but they don't know a whole lot about
you Bart Thawne yet next big thing
Malcolm Merlyn so it was fun to see John
Barrowman back but I didn't really like
the way they used him in this episode he
seems fairly low on the totem pole
within the Legion of Doom like they're
the rod he's the carrot like he's like
look I'm gonna make a deal with you we
can get everybody back I can get Tommy
back you can get Laurel back most of the
planning in the episode was thanks to
him like he played Eliot Ness against
the legend so that they could get back
on board their ship and just destroy it
get the amulet and get off the entire
reason for this was just to get the
other piece of the amulet so that they
could use the compass to find the
speeder of destiny so obviously Serra
does not take Merlin's deal and she has
like a big row with Martin Stein over
his daughter but eventually says you
know maybe it doesn't matter so much
that we protect the timeline
maybe our family is more important so
that just leaves you a little back door
for her to maybe save Laurel maybe
there's some big explanation with what's
going on on arrow so I'll talk more
about that when I do arrow videos just
because some of you might not be
watching that right now but a lot of
this all flows together with what's
happening on the flash and arrow so it
helps if you watch all three shows but
thus far like for this first half of
this second season I feel like the
show's much better they're having a lot
more fun just jumping around to
different genres different periods in DC
history and they're making use of really
big mythological things like the spear
of destiny if you're gonna have a big
team-up show like this then obviously
your finale has to be huge like whatever
the villains are trying to do has to be
big so spear of destiny is about as big
as you can go like the next biggest
thing would be for the reverse-flash
to steal the helmet of fate and become a
speedster dr. faith that would actually
be a pretty badass costume but that
actually reminds me so the reverse-flash
especially in that intro scene where
they kind of
teased him talking to Al Capone where is
like what is this Halloween and they
just kind of chuckle at each other well
it's really Christmas so my one problem
with what they're doing with the
reverse-flash right now is that he is
way too nice he doesn't have friends
like he refers to the Legion of Doom as
his friends like it seems almost like he
and damian darhk-- are old drinking
buddies now
but you Bart Thawne is one of those
people that's so smart and feels he's so
much smarter than everyone else that he
just can't talk to anyone he's just a
complete [ __ ] he just spends most of
his time putting others down or trying
to kill people or telling them to shut
up that's why you don't see him working
with a lot of people in the flash comics
usually it's him by himself acting alone
like some grand plan during those brief
periods where he is forced to work with
other people he absolutely hates it he
cannot stand anyone else so with
anything what I'm hoping to see from the
reverse-flash on legends of tomorrow is
that eventually the Legion of Doom will
just eat itself alive like eobard thawne
is the most powerful person on their
team everyone else is a good fighter but
he's the only one that has legit super
powers so what I'm hoping is is if
somebody ends up killing damian darhk--
or killing merlin again or seemingly
kill them it'll be the reverse-flash to
do it it won't be the heroes evil will
turn on itself but let me know in the
comments what did you guys think of the
episode and what do you think about them
using the spear of destiny to erase
Barry Allen from the timeline now I say
that but that's only the reverse flashes
plan Malcolm Merlyn does not care about
Barry Allen damian darhk-- also does not
care about Barry Allen at all
so future wars the sabotage stuff the
reverse flashes plan that will all play
out in the back half of the season we'll
learn more about it but that gets into
some flash storylines stuff that's
happening on that TV show it all kind of
blends together so that's why it helps a
lot if you watch the other TV shows but
just like I normally would if they do a
storyline from another TV show I'll try
to explain it just in case you guys
haven't watched it so no worries in just
a reminder legends of tomorrow is going
to come back January 24th that's the
same night that the flash is coming back
it's going to air right after the flash
so the new schedule will be flash on
Tuesdays then
legends of tomorrow then arrow no DC TV
on Thursdays I think the reason they did
that is to try and boost ratings just
because the flash is really strong
leaden and they want to have like all
their DC TV shows grouped together so if
you think it's weird it's really just a
ratings thing no worries so what's gonna
happen next is I'll post that flash
trailer video then I'll post my
spider-man Q&A then we'll have some Game
of Thrones Walking Dead finale on Sunday
but congratulations to this week's flash
ring giveaway winner Carson Alan please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there is a new round that's
started in this video I'll just remind
everyone when I post that flash trailer
video while you guys wait for that the
post you can click here for my
spider-man trailer videos and you can
click here to learn all about savat are
on the flash thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight